pounds to sense it smells so good in
here we're keeping things organic this
month and a vendor from the district at
Green Valley ranch's Farmers Market is
here to kind of give us one way one
really special way to celebrate organic
September so let's welcome Mary and
Scott of Baker Creek Lavender Farm
welcome to the show thank you like I
said it smells like a dream here in one
of my dreams in life is to just kind of
frolick through and explore a lavender
farm and you guys have one locally
well actually we are based in southern
Utah oh Southern excuse me
two and a half hours from here that's
you know it's a it's a quick drive or a
quick flight absolutely now tell us
about your farm
yep it's uh on the family ranch it's 250
acres and the farm is six acres we have
a little over 2 200 plants 18 different
varieties of lavender they're called
cultivars and and uh we distill
all of them separately so each lavender
plant has its own unique smell that is
incredible so you wouldn't know how
so I hear that you distill yourself and
you have all kinds of different products
at the farm to purchase yeah yeah we
utilize our lavender and all our
products and we grow totally organically
and no insecticides and herbicides so
it's a
good good pair 100 pure lavender we love
100 pure and Mary let's talk about p
Ure Farm if they
if they come down to Southern Utah and
come visit your farm during blooming
season that's correct Bloom season is
June and July we open the farm up for
visitors beginning the first of June and
we're usually harvested by the end of
July
we will be posting when we open we are
just a short little two and a half hour
drive from Las Vegas and it's beautiful
country to come in and not only to visit
our lavender farm but to sit by our
Creek and and just enjoy the the area I
am down that's like I said a dream of
mine now lastly here you know Lavender
is not just for scents and oils what
else can you use lavender for we hand
make all the products that are on this
table which is that we we do sell
everything at the farmers markets and at
our farm when we are open but we make
lotions and soaps and and our little
sachets with our culinary buds in them
uh we have our lavender essential oils
here if you'd like to smell one of those
as I send it back over to Mercedes I'm
going to go ahead and get a little sniff
of this Mercedes awesome it's you